what I do what 64 canola
welcome everybody welcome to westerly
planning and happy New Year to you all I
hope you're all feeling well
I'm hoping my voice will continue for
the rest of the evening because I'm
struggling a little bit there mmm right
just for reference my name is Mark
Cargill I'm chairing the meeting this
evening we have no firearm scheduled so
if there is a fire alarm please make
your way outside the building and meet
in the carpark down by the side of the
windmill pub please note this is a
planning meeting with public
participation not a public meeting
therefore only people registered to
speak will be allowed to do so we are
being webcast so if you want to be seen
in the big wide world please if you
don't let me officer there for our
speakers this evening the microphones
you get too close to them it gets
distorted so just a little bit away from
it and speak it clearly and you should
be all right
right the sequence events is as follows
I will introduce the item supported by
the case officer offer description sound
empowered counselors were allowed to
speak for up to three minutes members of
the public and projecting allowed to
speak for up to three minutes and then
the applicant would learn to speak for a
committed time either three or six
minutes I will give a 30-second warning
before times over board members are then
allowed to speak for five minutes at all
stages and members the computer are
allowed to ask questions following the
presentation right following that the
members of them able to question the
case officer on technical issues falling
let me open to debate and then a vote
all this is detailed in your agenda may
I ask you please to turn your mobile
phones to off or silent please thank you
right I'd like to start the meeting
apologists Thank You chairman to
apologize from counsel of ordering and
from councillor Giles with whom castor
fielding is substituting I just forgot
to say could you introduce yourselves
start from my right place
balance shape you from committee
services Ross chambers legal services
I'm Richie garden and planning manager
and I'm just going to make a statement
in terms of what my role here
tonight its tracks along with the
officers there's an impartial advisor to
the committee
it's to help any help answer any
questions which arise and I'm bound by
the code of Professional Conduct to the
rural town planning Institute and during
the course of the meeting I may seek to
understand and test the views being
expressed by committee members this is
done to ensure that the final decision
made by the committee is best placed to
withstand any subsequent challenge
committee members can balance the
planning issues as they consider
appropriate and they're not bound by the
case officers recommendation in the
agenda or by verbal advice provided this
evening thank you good evening my name
is David Jeffrey senior planning officer
Eddie wrench senior planning officer and
Amy flutes planning officer thank you
interest thank ya I am 17 and big 0 to
55 1 ful is in my ward I have made
representation I'm here an open mind I
will remain a part of the debate and
discussion thank you and I feel very
similarly and this is 17/2 double to 9 4
4 Rose Hill Priory Road I - I know I'm
aware of this item but I approach it
with a completely open mind right
catalyst for the first application they
thank you very much cancer right minutes
of meeting our members have agreed to
sign the minutes after the meeting thank
you okay on table right in that case
then we can move on to our first item of
the evening this is nice I'm going to
actually pull one forward because the
first item is 17/1 seven three six three
six - fall sunny fields Ludington Road
in this particular case this was
returned to this committee at the
request of the applicant because of
perceived error in the administration of
his slideshow we then have rescheduled
it for this evening
unfortunately the applicant is now
abroad and therefore we are going to
anger ask members to defer this item to
a subsequent meeting our members are
happy for me to defer it all those in
favor
thank you it's a good point the next
item which I would like to draw forward
is application 1702 395 such else
Garrity's south of a castle Road
Forrester
the objection which is by the ward
member has now with withdrawn on this
item and therefore I'm going to ask the
committee to delegate the decision to
officers are members happy for me to do
that delegate great thank you right
there for the first item then on the
agenda we going to discuss in detail now
is 17-0 one eight seven four special
dial house and thank you chair and as
you correctly stated this is application
1701 eight seven four four it's a
proposal dial house on the green in
Allston the site comprises the pool
house and grounds of dial house and sits
in the center of Augustine and it's
Conservation Area the application site
is shown by the red line boundary here
listed buildings and protected trees are
also shown in pink and green
respectively the site sits in the
junction effectively of the Rookery and
fairy lane this aerial photo shows dial
house the large Tudor style property
here set in substantial grounds and the
associated pool house
which is a similarly large property in
an arts and crafts style set alongside
and link attached to dial house the pool
house here is proposed to be converted
into five apartments this will require
the demolition of this element of the
property which links the to a separate
detached garage is also sought to the
northwest of dial house this aerial
photo shows the rear of dial house where
it is also proposed that an orange rebe
constructed in this location which will
form a three-sided courtyard and enclose
private immunity and garden space for
dial house the overall site layout is
shown in this plan shown clearly here
the converted main pool house the area
to be demolished the detached garage and
the Orangery I'll now turn to each of
those elements of the proposal in detail
this is the pool house the conversion of
the pool house envisages five apartments
with shared access from the rockery in
the same location as it currently exists
amendment to the landscaping and parking
arrangements to the front now provide
ten parking spaces within this area in
the aerial view you can see poor house
here the pool house I should say which
would be converted the area to its
frontage here which would be given over
to parking for future residents from the
rear the area here in blue would be
given over to garden and the Mina tea
space for those
seneschal future residents the proposed
front elevations would require only
modest alterations with the demolition
of the existing link in that location
there and then the additional addition
of a dormer window to the front and an
altered window to the projecting gable
to the rear it's a similar scenario a
single additional dormer would be
required the link would be demolished
that dormer there is the only addition
to the pool house this plan also shows a
detail of the Orangery there this is the
pool house as seen from the Rookery and
from the rear of dial house now just
break away momentarily to a couple of
videos that demonstrate these areas in
detail this is the frontage from the
rockery
with dial house itself the pool house
hidden you can see parking and amenity
space on the rockery
from within the grounds of the pool
house this area would be amended in the
landscaping to provide parking this is
the gable elevation of the pool house
itself a neighboring parking and storage
building which would remain unaltered
this time
finally all note all of this is enclosed
within a large red brick wall between
the Rookery Ferry Lane and the property
in question this is the frontage of Dial
house the house itself the link which
would require demolition and the
frontage of the very substantial pool
house areas for parking would be in here
turning to the proposed detached garage
this slide shows the arrangements for
that it would include a new access off
of the Rookery the proposed elevations
are shown in this slide
detailed to reflect the design and
materials of dial house itself and its
neighbor this photo shows a view from
the Rookery towards the location of the
detached garage this is from within the
site itself looking at the location of
the detached garage and its arrangement
with the neighbor this photo shows the
overall frontage of the property from
the Rookery turning to the proposed
Orangery as we call i'm sure the
location of the proposed Orangery is
there to the side of dial house is
really an elevation these proposed
elevations for the conservatory is shown
and detailed to complement the existing
elevations of dial curbs
it is a substantial conservatory in the
form of an orange er II that seems
appropriate given the scale of the
property in opposite views this photo
shows that location in greater detail
and this image shows the rear elevation
of dial house that concludes the
presentation on the basis of the
foregoing and the considerations
detailed within the officers report it's
therefore recommended that the Planning
Manager be authorized to ground for
planning permission subject to the
conditions and notice within the report
thank you thank you our first speaker
was to be councillor frankly but an
unfortunate or no knees ill he contacted
me today
and so our first speaker will be a mr.
Chris Fox chairman of Elston villages
Association thank you Chris it's a
button at the bottom and three minutes
in no time thank you can you hear me
not too close I've got quite a lot to
get through so okay
the ABA role is to preserve the village
for the benefit of all villagers to
assist us in this we refer to the
Alveston Conservation Area guidance
produced by Stratford District Council
in 1992 and also to the village design
statement created by the ABA and adopted
by SDC in 2015 both of which offers
supplementary planning guidance the ABA
continues to object to the planned
application on a number of specific
planning points two letters of objection
are on record and should be considered
alongside the additional 17 letters
objection and letters raising serious
concerns as to the negative impact that
mr. Bowman would have on the village
it's important to note that the ABA has
not received any comment supporting this
application and also that the Alveston
Conservation Area guidance has not been
referred to in the committee report even
though Tom house is included within it
the Alveston Conservation Area guidance
produced by SDC identifies that the
green submerges and lack of curbs in the
village has been an important
contributing factors to the character of
the village and that they must be
maintained in addition the village
design statement requires that grass
verges and grains must be protected and
for the street scene to be preserved or
enhanced these statements are to be used
as supplementary planning guidance
through the planning process to preserve
the royal
character of the village clearly if the
development was to be granted in a new
driveway cuts through the extensive
green outside the properties boundary
and through the boundary wall the
planning process would have failed to
maintain protect preserve or enhance the
rural nature of this conservation
village or the street scene the village
design statement also states that all
developments was being keeping with the
rural nature of the village and the
urban characteristics should be
discouraged there all characteristics
sorry the wrong character of the village
has been positively influenced over many
years by the creation and preservation
of the greens open spaces and with the
many individual homes of various designs
including several listed properties
significantly there are no blocks of
flats in this planning permission sorry
if this planet permission was to be
granted it would be an unwelcome
precedent the block of flats will be
created through the significant
intensification of an existing property
designed as a single dwelling and as a
result of the impossible for the rural
character of the village to be
maintained or preserved but likely to be
negatively affected forevermore by the
introduction of an obvious urban element
to the village this would oppose the
village design statement under
Conservation Area guidance the
application includes two parking spaces
for each flight including some gouging
which was most likely used to stores
there is no visitor parking the green of
very lane opens ablaze and are often
full of parked cars belonging to
existing residents their visitors and
customers of the fairy pub an additional
entrance would remove some of the
available road parking and would
therefore add to congestion in what is
considered to be the heart of the
village the additional vehicle movements
turn from the flats would increase the
pressure on what is already a densely
populated and often heavily congested
part of the village the AVI asked the
committee to support our objection and
refuse planning permission thank you
thank you George a bit quick two seconds
left so welcome thank you very much
indeed members there any questions you'd
like to ask okay thank you very soon
Thank You next speaker then is Georgia
Simpson
mr. Simpson I appreciate that you were
expecting six minutes I appreciate that
you will have a presentation to make
because obviously the first speaker was
not available but if you could reduce
yours your time down as quickly as
possible please
okay thanks very much thanks willing to
speak just a little bit of background
I'm a local I have the local orthodontic
practice I'm not a developer so I'm not
particularly or favored with how these
things work but I'll just sort of
explain why I arrived at this I
purchased the house and it needs
considerable investment when I set out
to kind of try and come up with a
project
I understand I understand rightly saw
that it will be sensitive no matter what
we did on this site my I came I
approached it with a view to try and
minimize the impact and actually
preserve as much as we could of the
actual visual appearance of what's
what's already there the I can
understand why there are objections
given that it's an important house and
it's actually in a sensitive part of the
village I think in terms of the in terms
of trying to support the case I think
it's the best possible use of a what's
actually a very large and redundant
building I think this is actually at a
time when there's a lot of pressure on
local councils to find more housing I
also feel that there isn't any very
housing there are a lot of detached
houses with large gardens so there
aren't many options for anyone to get
into Alveston there are a lots of people
around who would like the option and
including downsizes
so it gives them more varied
accommodation I believe there are flats
in Alveston a lot was mentioned
previously that there weren't I believe
there are on the new state the pool
itself the pool building I think it's
detracts architectural II from the main
house it wasn't obviously part of the
original design or build it's a 1980s
pastiche of a Tudor style building so I
think in terms of its merit I think
separating it distinctly from the habit
from the main house would improve dial
house the objections that we've had
predominantly aren't from people who
were local on the green there actually
were remote from from actually you would
argue would have a potential biggest
impact on the air and you saw the
pictures in terms of the parking on a
day to day basis I agree that the pub
increases the parking for transient
periods when the pub's busy biggest
objection which is the common theme is
in relation to parking
since the objections originally we've
doubled the amount of parking that we
have and I think people's fears should
be allayed given that I'm sure people
would prefer to park behind a gated car
parking which is safe and protected next
to their accommodation rather than
remotely on the village green the it's
with the Highways Agency and the Senior
Planner a support support the scheme and
I hope that we've alleviated the main
issue and the main concern regarding the
house I think it's very difficult when
change comes along I think most of us
don't like change quite often but I also
think it's important for villages to
survive and thrive you do need sometimes
to move a little bit there is a huge
demand for housing and I think I can't
see a better project and a better use of
in terms of sustainability and then a
redundant large building which is what
this is
I think I unofficially or by hearsay I'd
heard that this was likely to be
rejected by committee and I hope that
you'll give it a fair consideration from
what you hear tonight before you leave
would you mind just there's a few
questions at manias council Lawton and
council reaches Thank You chairman good
evening mr. Simpson thanks a lot um just
one thing you you you said in your
speech there that this 1980s building is
redundant what is it useful it houses a
large swimming pool which almost fills
the building but it was actually put in
in the 1980s so the designs old so the
cost of running it is prohibitive the
space that you see or the building that
you see is actually just has a ground
floor so there is no insulation and
since we bought the house since we moved
in the house it's never been used okay
thank you
parking is obviously an issue not just
isolated to your side but across our
district and clearly introducing fire
flats will introduce more cars you
talked about parking that you doubled
your original assessment of spaces
provided I want to understand a bit more
about how you came to that assessment
clearly you've got a huge amount of
available land there
what consideration was given to of
providing again more than you already
have I took advice from the architect as
I suggested I'm not a developer and I
took advice from my architect who's
who's local lives in Stratford and
there's been a lot of schemes and the
same thing applies to where we're having
the entrance my preferred option would
have been to have it in the wall to
create a new entrance with the drive
turning so as you look at the building
it would be almost adjacent to the the
existing gate but when we took advice
from
regarding that in that way we would have
preserved the hedge potentially and the
green which will some of which would be
lost
any other questions focus thank you very
much thank you thanks Don next speaker
the mister counsel Ross could you use
that one it's already on oh thank you
counselor when you enter okay I just
want to start by saying that all the
objections are from local people that
live locally to the Don house so let's
start by going directly to the main
issue there are not enough parking
spaces for this proposed development ie
there are no Vista car parking spaces
provided vistas will be forced to park
on the green where residents park mostly
and will cause even more congestion than
there already is why hasn't the planning
officer addressed this concern with the
applicant all of the comments made on
the website mentioned this and yet the
officer has not addressed this as an
issue of congested parking along the
green in a conservation area it's
interesting that highways did not
mention visitor parking maybe it didn't
occur to him highways are not always
right in their assessments as you know
please be mindful before considering
approval that you could easily ask for
this application to come back to
committee with at least two more spaces
to park within the development and I
mean properly laid out parking spaces as
an addendum shouldn't we as a planning
authority insists that Vista parking is
considered on all developments proposed
in our district parking is the most
talked about problem in our district and
we as a planning authority could make a
huge difference if we were to insist on
enough parking spaces before allowing
developments to go ahead one of the
points the planning officer poses is
having some impact upon the conservation
areas loss of the verge on the highway
and its impact on the street scene it
will have an impact on the street scene
again I reiterate it's a conservation
area and by changing the landscape
myself and the residents believe it will
have a detrimental effect
Treece yes there'll be a lot of trees in
a conservation area some
well-established ones at that is that
okay to say let's lose them by replacing
the new trees within the development I
don't think so
trees are important in themselves but
even more crucial to the street scene
and the scape of the area if you look at
the Alveston village design statement on
pages 8 & 9 it states very clearly how
important it is to keep the rural nature
of the village by losing trees that
really morality is compromised I come
back to the president of allowing flats
in the village where there aren't any
there are no flats in Alveston believe
me my concern would be that it opens it
up to anyone wishing to develop on land
in Alveston that flats will be the
answer to a housing problem let me make
it absolutely clear that upmarket
two-bedroom flats in this proposal would
not be affordable to the masses they
most likely would be taken up by those
who wish to have second homes rather
than local people as they would be
unaffordable to most I know we can't
look into the future but setting this
precedent is going to open it up if you
reminded to approve this and I hope that
you take my comments about parking very
seriously then very strict construction
conditions must be put in place this
isn't just about timings this is more
about large laws and building vehicles
accessing the development and being able
to turn within the development to come
out frontwards if this can't be done and
I suggest that it should be made
possible for it to be done for the
safety of all residents and those cars
parked on the green lorries cannot turn
round once they go past the entrance to
this proposed development they will get
stuck here's a photo of one being stuck
there must be no parking of large
vehicles along the side of the village
green cars will not be able to get past
larger vehicles and more importantly
those larger vehicles once parked by the
green would not be able to turn round I
reiterate that this is a conservation
area and we must have all time to
protect its morality and that of a
village street scene so please committee
ask that visitor parking is provided
properly spaced and marked out as
visitor parking that the verge remains
intact and a properly constructed
building plan is put in place for
everyone's safety
sanity and ask the applicant to come
back once these issues have been
addressed
please do not support this application
until these issues have been sorted
thank you
Thank You counselor there are any
questions you might ask and just want
clarification for your reference regards
policy and visitor spaces that I believe
is in the emerging policy yeah it is yes
and it should be considered on all
developments in this district thank you
thank you very much all right we can now
move into any technical issues cattle
Richard I think he you just talked about
the merging policy on parking I'd like
one of our officers to please explain it
to us very briefly if they can you're
looking you want me to explain what's in
it all the status of it all both both
okay at the current stage it is very
early in its progress it is due to
become a supplementary planning document
so it sits within the bundle of local
development framework documents
alongside the core strategy and it
informs it at a more detailed level at
the current time as you'll be aware the
district doesn't have any parking
standards so we judge each case on its
own merits the proposed parking
standards that are emerging I would
recommend that they're given very
limited right because they haven't been
subject to public scrutiny or
consultation but for the benefit of
members something like a 2 or 3 bed
wearing
require to allocated spaces for instance
and therefore each dwelling on this
scheme would need to use bases so the 10
provided would meet the emerging
guidance on that in terms of visitor
spaces again the emerging guidance says
naught point 4 spaces for dwelling so
there would be a requirement for 2
basis if weight was going to be given to
this guidance hopefully that answers
your question that is very helpful thank
you in terms of how far along it is all
you've said this is early that doesn't
really tell me a huge amount early could
mean it's just started evidently that's
not the case at what point is this going
to go under public scrutiny be put
through the recruiting consultation and
then what happens after that how quickly
is going to become policy I can't answer
that question with any certainty because
I'd have to rely on my policy colleagues
to give me somebody rough guide will
define the timeline I wouldn't wish to
mislead committee I couldn't say it
could be six months it could be a year I
really don't know
I wouldn't expect it to be more than a
year she'll say Casa Fargo the only
reason I'm asking that is because in my
mind
given this is an emerging policy it does
hold more weight than it's been
suggested that we give it any of the
technical questions yeah trees on site
what's being removed and why there would
be pear trees removed in this location
here and this ancillary sort of an
amenity grass and shrub planting area
would be reduced here no tree removals
can you show us that on a photo the the
two by the by the wall
I do have an additional photo that shows
those trees from within the site and
have to show that that the chairs
discretion
so from from within the site here the
trees which would be removed would be
within this grass verge up to here
effectively would be trimmed back and
then this shrub area here would also be
widened so I could see one is there
another one all that first one right
next to the world okay all right I
mentioned was made during the
presentations about the rural nature
obviously this is the village and the
fact that the new entrance for the
camels should not have curves is there
anything that's in the plans for that
there aren't detailed plans of that
construction detail at the moment should
members consider it appropriate
condition could be applied to require
that okay the other one of course as
mentioned was about the traffic
management I know you've got there's
many old conditions a traffic management
plan but would that include egress and
they certainly the the pricey of a
condition which you refer to I think is
condition
10 which is for a construction
management plan that could be broadened
out to include specific requirements for
access and egress of larger vehicles
should members consider it appropriate
to guide offices in that direction any
other technical questions councillor
fielding
you look at the plan on the my right
you'll at the plans left there looks
like there's an entrance can we go back
please there looks like there's an
entrance done no the other go keep
getting the other way right the way
around there's an entrance there could
that not be I know it's not part of the
planning application but could that not
be utilized rather than going across the
the green and also added in as extra car
parking if they're putting new garages
at the other end of the house the
application that's before members
doesn't consider that and I think I can
I can provide some guess as to the
reason why this building here provides
storage and Goehring and would remain
within the applicants ownership even
after the fire departments were built
the expectation is that there would be a
wall built across the frontage here to
separate the two properties so in that
sense although there is you're correct
and access there there wouldn't be a way
of commuting across the frontage and
onto the other property so in that sense
this access would be required thank you
any other questions I'll open up for
debate
thank you the principle of the flats I
have no particular issue with I don't
think there's a danger of us setting a
precedent very clearly whenever we
review or consider a an application we
consider it on its own individual merits
so I don't think those oppressed tend to
be set there is no significant amendment
to that exterior of that building to the
to the change of the conservation area
in that sense my issue is with the
parking there is a substantial amount of
land there the red line has chopped in
areas in my view that are completely
ill-thought-out and inappropriate I
think that needs to go back for further
consideration by the applicant and his
architect there is a lot that could be
done there and given the emerging SPD to
which I apply significant weight and I
were being kind to refused this on that
basis with the view that anything coming
back would consider the parking
situation in more detail I do accept the
visited parking spaces I think that's
absolutely right I also think that the
traffic management plan needs enhancing
and also the the drive into the property
there to reflect the rural nature and
the existing roads there but I do wonder
about refusing it's simply based on
those for example two spaces whether or
not that would be saying that we could
actually delegate or take advice on that
for the officers to ensure that those
two spaces are included I can ask that
question the plan in front of you shows
ten spaces so if if you were to give
weight to the emerging policy on parking
then it would meet that in terms of the
residents if then you look at the
visitor spaces then two would be
required to my mind it would be possible
to provide two elsewhere on the site
perhaps in along the frontage there in
front of that green area
there's a possibility there and with
that in mind it would be possible to
delegate approval to offices subject to
the receipt of an appropriate plan
showing visitor parking perhaps to the
satisfaction your satisfaction chairman
that would be one option that's subject
to visitor parking in line with the SPD
the emerging SPD yes that the SPD says
to I think there's room for two on there
if the plan was amended to show that
yeah I like the idea of the extra two
car parking spaces but I think also a
councillor Richards that you'd think
with all that land would be an
opportunity to do that without eating
into existing trees and greenery which
make a contribution to the the character
of the area so I think what might have
been suggested was using some of the
other land for parking rather than
trying to fit any more car parking in
there and that is a bit different and
we'll probably I would suggest need to
refuse it on that and if you refuse it
on only car parking if if it's only car
parking that's the problem I don't see
why we shouldn't be owning the layout
the fact that they're putting in some
small units there particularly for
people who want to downsize is a
beautiful part of the world to be but I
do agree with the car parking it is a
problem throughout the districts and I
think Betty you should be made a car
parking area and but I did also I think
it should be up to the officers to look
into it and sort it out thank you
clarify what I'm trying to say before
it's helpful the information we've just
been given by both our legal and our
planning officer what consular carriages
pointed out is that the the risk of
Central under our buildings there that
evidently have been used for car parking
in the past now we're not in a position
to be dictating to the owner of the land
in the property how they use that I
think it would its ill-thought-out by
not doing so now knowing we can apply
the SP that the emerging SPD and the
additional house the additional spaces I
think we might be on thin ice if were to
refuse on the basis of moving the red
line and utilizing other buildings I
agree it's the right thing to do I think
it would be an appropriate thing to do
but I don't think it would hope it would
be upheld if we refused in that basis
given the other option your view would
be interesting well it's it's the
conservation area it's not just there
it's the effect that any extra car
parking would have on the conservation
area no so I think you need what we have
before us to me is it is not good enough
on parking evolving policy or not 2 / 2
/ space is good but it doesn't take a
count of visitors that would be visitors
and this is a busy area and this and you
don't want extra cars parked there so
I'm not saying go away and use one of
your other carriages I'm saying this
isn't good enough and and by
intensifying that area as a car park
does nothing to to enhance in fact it
would do more to detract from the rural
nature so I think sticking an extra two
car parking spaces in there I'd like to
ask the officers if that if we're to
grant this with the condition that we
we've already mentioned about the
additional spaces is it in the
applicants gift then to be able to offer
up areas that are outside the red line
for that parking area but still within
his blue line ownership it would it
could possibly considered a different
scheme if you start moving the red line
but my my comments earlier were made on
the basis that there was room within the
red line if we go outside the red line
they would certainly you'd certainly
need to restart the application if not
submit a fresh one my name would be that
if that's if it's significantly outside
the red line I don't think it would be
significant although I get your point I
think the message is coming across I'd
like to think the message is being is
getting across to the applicant what
we're looking for I think given that
condition if we can put our condition on
I'd be happy I'd become more comfortable
granting and give them given the debate
that we've had okay I'm picking up this
I think I'm with Casarez on this
particular point driver proposed it for
this with the amendments we talked about
traffic plan the drive to reflect the
rural nature and also the to visitors
spaces well I'm happy to second that
members we have a proposal for to grant
plan provision with the conditions about
the traffic management plan the drive to
reflect the rural nature and the
additional to visitor spaces all those
in favor
thank you this committee therefore
resort to grunt clang permission 417 -
oh one eighty seven for thoughtful thank
you the next item on the agenda is 17025
1/4 land adjacent to telephone exchange
Bailey Road snitterfield the sentient
officer is Amy no Eddie sorry I
apologize Eddie
Thank You chair the application is for
the erection of three dwellings the site
is located on the north western edge of
the village of Smithfield off the barely
road as denoted here by the black dot
the application site is currently a car
park adjacent to public right-of-way s
d15 1b
the site is within the West Midlands
green belt and his kids send it to be
within the built-up area boundary of the
village the site can be seen here
outlined in red to the center of the
screen this is an aerial view of the
site showing the surrounding residential
development and the telephone exchange
located to the west of the area which is
just here this is the proposed site plan
showing three dwellings amenity space
and parking and maneuvering areas this
slide shows the front and rear
elevations of the proposed dwellings
which would be constructed in red brick
and have slate roofs this photo is taken
from the barely rode along the access
road to the proposed development this
photo is from the car park looking
eastwards towards the rear of the
properties along hive build close and
the public right-of-way this photo is
looking in the opposite direction with
the site access off to the left and the
telephone exchange in the background
this photo shows the field to the north
of the site and finally this photo is
looking southwards towards the rear of
the properties along Bailey Road chair
there are a number of additions to the
report which are detailed in the update
sheet and the recommendation is to grant
permission subjects the conditions and
notes outlined on page 45 of the agenda
thank you thank you very much any our
first speaker is councillor Denis tweed
from us and if your parish council
council
mmm you have three minutes in your own
time thank you thank you good evening
and I would like the third slide to be
put on the screen please followed by the
fourth one yep that's fine
that one that one to start off with and
then the fourth slide I think it was
that one to follow please okay it is
worth reiterating that the snitterfield
parish council supports development of
this brownfield site with up to three
dwellings as stated and compliant with
the draft referendum version of the
neighborhood plan submitted for approval
by the council at its next meeting on
15th of January the parish councils
objection essentially concerns our
perception of grouse over development as
proposed by this application
specifically this essentially relates to
the density massing height and limited
amenity space and facilities for vehicle
use the three large three-bedroom family
dwellings proposed would result in a
site density conflicting with the
substantially lower density of adjoining
properties on three sides of the site
terrorists and semi-detached former
local authority housing from 1960s and
70s and a recent affordable housing plan
intended Wellings one of the proposed
dwellings is of two and a half stories
the other two are a similar height and
also equipped with roof space windows
there's all creating a significant
massing issue in contrast with
surrounding dwellings all of two-story
construction this is all contrary to
requirements of policy cs9 and
Neighborhood Development plan policies
be1
and
vitu and in particular to b2 which
requires building heights to be lower
towards the edge of the village from
landscape and countryside considerations
annuity space for the three dwellings is
severely limited due to essential
provision of parking spaces and garages
this is contrary to the intent of cs9
although generally adequate parking
space for number three is insufficient
to comply with Neighborhood Development
Plan Policy be6 vehicle maneuvering and
movement force provisions are confined
to the minimum required for each
dwelling to secure Highways Authority
approval there is no provision for
visitors or delivery and services
vehicles so no compliance with the
emerging SDP and maneuvering to leave
the site forwards would rely on
encroaching on the designating parking
and 30 seconds please
for the dwellings it's also conflicts
with policy cs9
long term use of the site to date after
demolition of the original garages has
been for car parking by local residents
having no off street parking facilities
amounting to up to 20 vehicles these
will be displaced to on street parking
which would be unsafe on the nearby
bailey road especially in proximity to
the site access ask you to finish now
please okay thank you thank you very
much members any questions all right
I've got one first and we are seeing a
number of these types of site the garage
sites coming through now through the
system have you when you are actually
assessing this site did you consider the
access for emergency vehicles of the
single track at Road or access into the
site this has been considered and in
respect of ambulances and and police
vehicles
access is generally generally just
adequate but again for the maneuvering
those vehicles would rely on residents
parking spaces of one or more to be
vacant fire engine access absolutely not
the fire engine could enter the site but
would have to reverse out to Bailey Road
I the assumption has to be that the fire
engine would park in Bailey Road and
would be required to run hoses the
length of the access track up to the
affected property Thank You councillor
sweet you talked about the emerging
special development plan that it does
allocate this site for three houses but
that the the ones that been proposed
appears to be an over development have
Israel is there a preconceived idea of
in that development plan of the size of
housing or the style in which it's been
provided could if you could expand on
what you did on that please there's no
specific requirement other than a
requirement in policy be1 that the
development should respond to the local
character such the bits of a density in
keeping with the character of the
surrounding development and landscape
and I alluded to that in my speak again
policy be2 requires the delivery of
sustainable development assisted by an
appropriate building density which is
designed to enhance the character and
quality of the local area the
explanatory notes that follow in policy
be to show that there is an expectation
that new developments will be will
reflect the existing low-density
character of the village
height scale and massing of new
buildings should have regard to the
context of the site and the surrounding
area I've also mentioned the specific
requirement for the height of buildings
on the periphery of the village lower
towards towards the periphery to assist
in the assimilation of new developments
into the surrounding countryside in the
landscape these are specific provisions
in the neighborhood development plan but
naturally they're expressed in a fairly
general context but I think we believe
they're entirely relevant to our
objection to this development as it's
been submitted not to the develop not to
the concept of development itself but
that this development would constitute
an inappropriate if I may have one on
you mentioned be6 in your speech which
is the parking and provisions could you
remind me what the content of b6 is
please my putting you on the spot a bit
three minutes is just not enough to get
into this sort of level of detail but I
think you could ask the officers if you
want to technical we can answer the
question
it's Planning Council Swedish from
center field crash council like he's
best close to those Wellings
dwellings comprising two or more
bedrooms must provide at least two
off-road parking spaces excluding
garages but including car Ford's the
rationale for excluding garages has
explained that that general generally it
is seen that garages are not used for
car parking they are used for
supplementary storage or services use
amenity of general meaning to use and
the number three unit has one garage and
one parking space encourage just to cook
is it be to the comments about the lower
Heights towards the edge of the visit
village comes into each one is before
the garage that were pulled on did the
local residents who couldn't afford to
rent the garages to their park on the
road on the main road at the Valley Road
many of them as far as is known actually
rented the garages the garages as so
often in the air in areas local
authority or former local authority
housing largely fell into disrepair and
rents were put up and so for a time
occupancy of the garages diminished the
garages were then removed demolished and
nearby residents resumed use of this
area for parking and that has been in
place for many years is in the
neighbourhood plan what size houses had
you individualized maybe I missed that
point earlier on I think yeah okay
thank you very much Dean castle-like
speaker is Daniel Jackson the agent you
don't know you have three minutes in you
and time thank you
thanks very much good evening members
I'm here to this evening speaking in
support of the application at
snitterfield and I thank the officers
for their constructive feedback and
assistance today to fully endorse the
positive recommendation for approval
which have been has been reached I
should be clear already this is a bound
field site in the middle of the village
which has been allocated by the parish
council for three dwellings being a
brownfield site inside the village
boundary the application passes all of
the policy tests set out within the
local plan and a neighbourhood plan in
terms of principles of residential
development at centerfield as you may
know as a category 3 local service
village and deemed a sustainable
location for new Hansy the prophecies
themselves have been attractively
designed sensitive for the local
architecture and meet all of the design
requirements set out in the district
design guide including distance
separations standards for private
amenity space and also all of the
parking standards I might just add at
this point that I think the site plan on
the screen has been superseded I think
there is more up to day one showing
vehicle tracking for larger vehicles and
two slightly amended parking scheme but
there are no objections for many of the
statutory penalties and we work closely
with county highways to meet ensure an
adequate access and turning space for
larger vehicles and delivery vans as
part of the proposals existing rights of
access to property fronting Bailey Road
have been retained and actually where
necessary we've even approved improve
the right of the use residents that
didn't previously have rights of access
to their back gardens throughout the
application period the applicant has
left the site open as a gesture of
goodwill and allow people to park there
and continue to do so in the short term
we appreciate this has been referred to
committee this evening on the request
that the Parish Council due to a small
number of local objections I would
however point out that there are letters
of support from those in the closest
proximity to the site with whom we've
worked very closely in the preparation
of this application we hope this is a
straightforward decision in line with
your own policy your office's
recommendation
and encouraging small developments on
brownfield sites and sustainable
locations which have been allocated for
such a purpose thank you very much thank
you very much
members do you have any questions cuz
Richard you referred to letters of
support my office's report tells me that
there's one that you have no
representation internet objection we'd
be update sheet from the closest
residents through the site okay thank
you any other questions thank you very
much and technical questions I'm now
going to ask the first one Eddie
how many bedrooms are there of these
properties please so become those so
unit one has basically its identified as
two bedrooms and one in the loft space
there's also a games room which
potentially could be used as a bedroom
so three or four bedrooms so that would
be the other two both have three
identified and then there is a similar
loft space which I think was a good
fight but isn't put down as a bed space
so they would be classified as three
beds as well so basically looking at two
three beds and a 3/4 bed thank you and
we then refer back to our previous
discussion on parking and the emerging
policy document on that would that
comply so the emerging one would be a
three bed word dwelling you're talking
about two spaces that are allocated and
again it would be 2/3 for the unit one
as well so three six or seven spaces
would be needed to be allocated and then
it would be point four of a space
her dwelling as a Vista parking so
that's one one point one I one point two
sorry so another one but generally see
talking around eight maximum we'd be
looking for thank you and secondly the
have rehabbed a response from the Fire
and Rescue Service on the accessibility
of this site we have had informal talks
with them unfortunately they weren't
able to respond by today's committee if
members were minded to approve it we
could do it subject to obviously them
being satisfied a fire vehicle could
either enter the site or that they could
adequately address any fire concerns
from probably the barely Road it's
possibly what we could do if members of
minded to do that I have two questions
if I may one is the site plan the agent
referred to an update is one of you
aware of an updated one should we be
aware of an updated one yes I am not
aware of one I think the only difference
is that they did maybe did some more
tracking rather than any actual movement
in terms of dwellings or gardens or
spaces I'm not aware of it as I'm not a
case officer but there may have been
some slight extra tracking details done
okay second question is about the
letters of support I can't see anywhere
in our update sheet there's been a
support am I missing something you aware
of any there was a letter objecting from
a neighbor and that was subsequently
withdrawn so the removal of an objection
rather than a direct support within no
letters to support okay thank you for
the clarification council feeling the
plan you showed from the Braley Road or
the photograph you had from the Brittany
Road no the other one it was a ground
level that was that one that track looks
remarkably narrow or narrower than the
three point nine meters that you've got
further on are
have you got any comments on that I
haven't measured it unfortunately yeah
all right crash students technical
issues are open to debate
carriage listening to the Parish Council
and the neighbourhood plan which seems
to be quite quite a long way forward and
thus I think we should be taking note of
it there be one on the density of houses
responding to the surrounding
development doesn't seem to be met the
low density height and massing a better
height but the massing doesn't seem to
be met but the height I think probably
is relevant when it comes to the part of
b2 when it's talking about lower Heights
towards the edge of the village and we
see a lovely development in villages
across the district where you have new
houses at the edge of a village next to
a field and the effect that has is in my
mind is awful so that's b2 b1 b6 as well
as you know if it's in there but in the
local policy it's not respecting the
local neighbourhood plan especially for
number three with its garage rather than
than parking space so essentially on
that on those grounds the local plan I
would be suggesting we thank you chair
our young I have a lot of sympathy with
the parish council and and I would echo
what councillor Kerry said um the
planning officers obviously looked at
this in accordance with core strategy
doesn't seem to put that much emphasis
on what the Senate or neighbourhood plan
says it just looks to me like the
applicant here is trying to fit
a caught into a pint pot I have no
problems whatsoever with the design of
the houses of no problems lots of
weather with the location and its
sustainability for limited residential
development there quite frankly I don't
think it agrees with the labor hood plan
I think it probably barely scrapes
through on our core strategy I'm very
concerned that as with the previous
application there seems to be no
provision for visitor spaces and we know
that Bailey Road is busy we know it's
narrow it's not suitable for people to
park on quite frankly and despite the
fact that there were less traffic
movements because the Robie 15 or 16
garages I'm just not happy with it I'd
love to see it come back in in a scaled
down mode possibly two houses possibly
three bungalows but I just I can't
support this I'm afraid so I would be
happy to second cancel the carriages
props proposal if it was one thank you I
entirely agree with the councillors have
just mentioned I the one thing I
disagree with council Lawton honest I
don't think this scrapes through on our
core strategy at all essential Promotion
Council have cut forward a very very
substantial objection to this they have
backed that up with a very concise and
full reasoning of why they've come with
an objection and I think that is
actually I wrote down four things
when one castle team tweed was speaking
about this the density massing and
height is contrary to our
cs9 my view and also contrary to the
emerging Smithfield Neighborhood
Development Plan overbearing and over
development of the site I think those
two go hand-in-hand
inadequate amenity space for the new
properties again contrary to current
course Russia cs9
and actually in my view the due to the
scale density massing and height of the
properties and they're actually
overbearing on the neighbors immunity
there is an impact on our neighbors
amenity
so those specifically presume could go
into one reason for refusal which is the
contrary to see at nine the other is in
relation to the parking again we
constantly see things come forward that
don't provide sufficient parking this
doesn't we've heard that already that
doesn't so I think that needs to go in
as well and also consideration for the
displacement of the cars they're going
to be moving to the front of the the
properties onto Bailey Road we've
already heard that the exit entrance
exits this is going to be pretty tricky
at the best of times you want the
displacement of those cars that are
gonna be parking either side of that
you're forcing cars to then enter the
main road onto the road halfway across
the road just to get around those cars I
think this is badly put forward I must
admit it the notes I made very similar
remembering that it is incumbent upon
this committee to to provide
high-quality design for our communities
and I don't feel it meets that criteria
it's overbearing as you mentioned the
massing of the buildings over the berm
to the site insufficient occupation so I
echo all of the all concern I still have
a concern about emergency vehicles and I
would be unhappy to support something
without seeing response from the Fire
Rescue Service as well so that's
something I can't I can't support this
in this form either so kastlevania do
you know right members did I have a
proposal to refuse on this one I'm happy
to propose it I don't particularly want
to go with overbearing on neighbors or
it is another Bailey Road you can say
it's never been nature if you wish I
think it's definitely overbearing within
well yes the neighbor from the from the
from the club and the view from the
countryside
I don't think we'd get away with
overbearing - the total local residents
I think it's the cumulative effect of
the points that I've raised I think all
go into one reached projection which is
cs9 I see no harm in that and by its
very nature density massing and height
of something if it's inappropriate and
that close to someone's property it's
going to have known for varying effect
on yeah are talking about effectively
over development of the site of which
there's various factors that result from
the over development you've touched on
quite a few here if I can just comment
on the the merits of those reasons
settlement pattern that's that's a
difficult one in terms of it does follow
the pattern of development in the area
although the plots the actual amount of
building in each plot is quite large so
there is a case to be made on that but
the actual footprint is too large for
the plots that they occupy the massive
development which has been touched on
and that's that's the overbearing
overdevelopment type arguments because
there's limited space between the
buildings that has an impact and it's as
an impact on I think you touched on the
countryside to the rear the design has
been mentioned that's that's a more
difficult one because the character the
area is quite simple because it's mid
20th century acts council stock so they
have designed a fairly simple design so
that again is more arguable the levels
of a mainland tea space they are small
for the size of the dwelling but equally
they back onto countryside so they would
have an open feel so I'd ask you to bear
that in mind in terms of neighbors
amenity the neighboring properties do
have fairly large plots so I think would
be hard to argue that one because nearby
dwellings are a long way from those
properties
so that's not as strong as some of the
other reasons give it the amenity space
of the neighbors go all the way up to
that edge so it's no growing on the
amenity space if I was going to enjoy my
back garden I had three buildings
looking over the top of it when I've had
open fields surely that still a valid
argument over varying affect on your on
the neighbors amenity area yes you can
take that into account
or all I would ask you to do is consider
the fact that that most people would
have used the area closest to that
property but yep I take your point
people may use it more down at the
bottom ago
I think they all come cumulatively into
one reason for objection which is as
I've already laid okay okay members
thank you so the vote before you is to
refuse planning permission for 17/2 pi5
1/4 for the reasons given all those in
favor
Thank You Cooney there for reals to
refuse plantation 76020 5 1/4 they kept
them yes clarification on parking thank
you very much members next item on the
agenda is 75071 1/4 and
it's Joseph
okay over to you Joseph
thank you
the salt is located in
stratford-upon-avon - real shortly Road
the application is seeking to one half
stories probably two bedroom dwelling in
the existing plot this plan shows a red
line boundary over re situated to really
soft Airy Road
this plan is shows the exact extent of
the character of the area as you can see
the application is sorted it's a really
short erode this is shastri road say
Andrew Crescent is the other side and
Somerton way which is a public
right-of-way runs adjacent to the side
the upper views of the site can only be
attained from when going in there and
the past which is access to the site
views from sometime way of protected by
a tree barrier there which is something
and there is this site is not a
situation any designated areas and then
no heritage assets within the vicinity
of the application the site I've already
mentioned is access between number 7 and
number 6 surety Road under an underpass
it needs into the existing among the
road into the existing bond weather site
which is located there this is all part
of the application sorry presently this
area is used for parking and I will go
into this further and the photos the
existing application it is a 1/2 storey
bungalow as you can see by the
elevations it's quite small in nature
these are the photos of the bungalow
when come in from the unpassed this is
the underpass which leads onto shotty
Road parking is available to the side to
the front and to the other side area
this is the rarely application as it
stands this is the houses longshots
erode and show that the bungalow is a
present very
/ Berenson studying long story short he
rode a lot more present which will be
seen in the street scene further on this
is a street scene of shorty road this is
two storey terrace character houses
presume mainly made out of red brick but
there is one render in the area this is
the rarity application site say Andrews
presents you can see why the maps to the
other case size just there you can see
this is very different it's mainly
two-story detached houses with garage
parking this is also just offshore erode
and it shows that white render is
available in the area and the mix a
palette that's available in the round
the surrounding area this is the
proposed plan as you can see that the
application is proposing to move it
slightly over to the northern boundary
and rather than extension this is once
again out of the plan is that going to
sit on the ground floor and existing
front floor this is the elevations of
the pros plan it will be extended to now
one and a half stories high two stories
high but it's still lower than what is
associated a long shorter erode kitchen
and garden area file again showing the
living room and the extension in the
kitchen area of proceeding out to the
rear of the application sorry as you see
members have been amazed made to the
plan to show that it does not sit within
its own vicinity within the plot and the
application is proposing white rendering
instead of brick finally on the update
Street up they see the ward Mandir has
remove the rejection but would like to
see the comprehensive construction
margin plan if approved to be
conditioned and officer recommendation
is for approval to build it do it to
remove the existing dwelling
bill disappeared as proposed reason for
bringing it to committee the reason is
brought to committee now is because the
the applicant is related to the one of
the flooding officers thank you very
much
right there are no speakers on this item
so we'll go to technical questions hmm
right moving on to debate our first one
technical question is there a
comprehensive construction plan because
obviously access into that area is very
very tight as you in the officer report
I have conditioned it to be once made
during this traffic conditions debate
members : Thank You chair I think this
is a very pleasant Billy I think it
mirrors what some in the vicinity and
I've got no problem with going with
officers recommendation I would propose
that the committee grant this
application thank you very much do I
have a seconder for that cancer coach
members the vote before you is to grant
fly information for 17 - OH - seven more
months after all all those in favor Asst
unanimous change very much indeed this
committee therefore resolves to grant
plans which of Seventeen's - OH - seven
more months at four
Thank You chairman the application sites
denoted by the black dot is a commercial
unit with in stratford-upon-avon town
centre the site each thread is of Henley
streets within the conservation area the
application site is not listed but there
are a number of listed buildings to the
north and east of the application site
which are read on the plan being shown
the proposal seeks permission to alter
the shopfront
specifically permission is sought to
alter and replace the window and door
openings to smooth rendering of the shop
front and external painting the advert
does not form part of this application
just to make you aware the floor plan
shows that the replacement windows would
allow some interaction between the unit
and the street as you can see that they
open up they are both fold in nature so
I'm now showing you an image and which
was taken from the applicants heritage
statement which shows the application
site in 1907 another image of the
applications that site is now being
shown and this was taken from the
heritage statement for the 2015 planning
application which granted the change of
use and alterations to Bart's walk the
image now being shown shows the site
currently the existing shop friend is
constructed from modern materials and is
not historic the application site can
now be seen looking in northwesterly
direction along Henley Street these
images show shop fronts to the northwest
of the application site the images now
show shop fronts which are directly
opposite to the north of the application
site and here are other examples of shop
fronts within the wider context of
Henley Street and this plan was taken
from the approve advert which is quite
good because it just shows and what the
proposed shop front would look like in
colour so there are four updates to note
on the update sheet and chairman the
recommendation is to grant the
application subject to the conditions
and notes as detailed and comfortable
for two
thank you thank you we have no speakers
on this item
therefore any technical questions is
there any way we can insist that all the
shops okay in that case then open for
debate
I think personally I'm looking around
the photographs that Amy is showing us
there is a completely diverse range of
frontages on in that Street I just don't
see this particular one having any and
having any complains about it my my
personal view so I'm quite happy to go
with the opposite recommendation now I
crave the eyes there is a variety of
there is a great shame that we can't we
don't all see the frontages that we did
have in the 1907 picture I think that's
wonderful
I'm actually very in keeping with the
Strafford style however it is what it is
and I will be proposing we grant
officers recommendation thank you I have
a proposal second a council Lorton
members the vote before you is to grant
a plan from issue 17s - OH two nine one
six four
all those in favor unanimous chair thank
you this committee therefore resource to
grant frankerz - seventeen - OH - nine
one six four thank you moving on to our
last item this is 17 so 2 - 9 4/4 Rose
Hill Priory Road Ulster I should just
wait for the speaker mr. client accounts
of Clyde Neil Sturgis he's just
returning I think he's just been so
spiffy all right then
ok and the presenting officers David
Thank You chair this is application 17
stroke zero two two nine four stroke ful
which is a retrospect sorry a
retrospective proposal at Rose Hill
Priory Road ulster site sits within
Ulster to the south of Priory Road the
works proposed include two ground floor
rear extensions raising the roof by 900
millimeters construction of three doors
to the rear meadow roof light to the
front and refacing the dwelling in
timber and render this plan shows the
application site in the context of the
conservation area and listed buildings
in pink and red respectively
this image shows Rose Hill before the
alterations were made those members all
know Rose Hill is set back from the road
and benefits from a substantial beech
tree in the front front garden which you
can see the lower bounds across the top
photo this slide shows the existing and
proposed block plans members will note
prior eatery which links Priory Road to
cross road along side number six Priory
Road in this location here that property
has been the subject of separate
planning applications for substantial
extensions as well the proposed
elevations are shown in this slide
front and rear in plan form the formerly
existing and proposed plans are shown
members will note the two ground for
extensions conversion of the garage as
well to living accommodation
this photo shows the view from Priory
Road with the roof alterations having
been undertaken this photo shows the
relationship between the development and
number six and the Catholic Center full
of you of that frontage showing mixed
residential building styles the rear
elevations and dormers are shown in this
view as initially submitted one of these
extensions would have benefited from a
balcony to the top but that was removed
through amendments this photo shows
again the relationship with number six
which itself as you see is under
renovation relationship with number two
it's shown in this photo the same
relationship with number two but this
time from the front a view of the
property from beneath the protected
beech tree it is listed TP owed and it's
within the conservation area this photo
shows views from the Catholic
Information Center this view is a street
scene on Priory Road looking to north
from the town end the large beech tree
here shows the position of the property
in question form a closer vantage point
tree is seen here these properties which
face onto Rose Hill listed frontage and
this photo shows that frontage in the
context of the BT tree chair there are
updates provided in the update sheet
these include details of a petition a
petition of support for the development
and details of an archeology report
which has been undertaken these do not
alter officers recommendations in favor
of the application as such the
recommendation is to grant planning
permission subject to the conditions and
notes within the report thank you thank
you very much our purse speakers
professor counselor like Neil Sturgis
you have three minutes in your own time
thank you gentlemen
is that mic in the right position thank
you yes as you've heard members part
repres respect it's a very model
situation ribbon to planning
applications and informal consultation
I'm not intending to go through the
history of this thing some of which was
bypassed us anyway
I simply wish to concentrate on three or
four outstanding issues as we the
planning committee see them after the
two applications and some of which are
already covered by your office's
recommendations
so the first if you really we still have
concerns up to the roof height in terms
of the general background but we think
you've probably gone past that the
garage conversion they can wanting to
convert the garage into habitable space
the officers recommendation cover part
of that but as we see it it removed car
parking and onto the drive just a very
long drive but nevertheless there'll be
more
which will affect the street scene as it
faces into the conservation all
materials can be submitted for approval
which the officer was already dealt with
the archaeological reports which not
sustainment has already dealt with which
leaves to issue is the balconies of
balconies as we saw them that as far as
we're concerned were to balcony to plan
with balustrade following the
consultation they've removed a
balustrade but they haven't changed the
window arrangement at the rear I don't
know whether you can see it on one of
your slide but they're the upstairs the
upstairs windows are still French
windowed permitting access to what would
previously the balconies from which they
removed a balustrade so what we've got
now as we see it is upstairs
print window with unfettered access onto
flat roomed with no balustrade so we
would ask that a condition being polis
that the upstairs rear windows should be
commenced the windows which would not
allow access onto the room 30 seconds
please it hasn't been considered
anywhere in the documentation but a
contractor's vehicle did demolish the
entrance wall to the property which
actually using the conservation zone so
we would request that whatever happens
the access will be restored to its
previous state thank you
you mentioned about the garage now being
used as habitable space and therefore
car parking will be on the drive an
obviously the front once onto a heritage
element on the the frontage is there
what are you suggesting is it screaming
to be put in place between there also
know that well the it's difficult
because of course the frontage of this
actually in this from our view where
we're looking from missile conservation
zone so if a frontage was put in two
master cars it would completely change
the aspect of the house in the
conservation zone so it's it's a
difficult one okay thank you
any other questions okay thank you very
much Gaza our next speaker is mr. Dave
plane under mr. max plane on behalf of
the applicants
they need help
three minutes in your own time good
evening everyone my name is Matthew
Flynn and I'm currently in the process
of completing the work on number four
Priory Road with my dad David firstly my
offer my sincerest apologies for any
disruption and stress you may have
caused as this was never our intention
the only reason what Dad annoyed took on
this project was because it's always
been a dream of ours to work together
and we both knew the previous tenants
who mentioned to us on a number of
occasions that they were keen to see a
positive change take place my family
over history with Ulster my mom lives in
Aero my Nana lives in Bleach field
Street my sister went to Austin grammar
and both my dad and I played for alster
football team that being said we really
do appreciate how special Oscar is and
how important it is that it remains
unspoiled hopefully after seeing the
revised plans for number four Priory
Road you will agree that we've improved
the street scene and we've addressed all
the objections of now and you have to my
dad firstly following on from that I
apologize unreservedly for the concern
and confusion we've caused with the
planning or rather lack of planning
concern we were advised at the start of
the project that our improvements the
Priory Road win the scope of permitted
development
I've Kalia accept our naivety in this
and would like to reassure you this this
is due to inexperience in property
development rather than any attempt
biased to ignore the due process when we
realized we needed full planning we took
a decision to raise the roof by 900
millimeters this is in keeping with the
neighborhood as there are no
single-story dwellings on Priory Road in
fact the neighboring property is number
two and number six are both two stories
either side once we remove the roof we
consulted with the enforcement officer
who agreed we should make the roof
watertight and complete the work for
security reasons and
looked a bit like a build inside so we
got on with that the we originally
planned for two balconies after
objection to that we've scrapped the
balconies and the doors are now I think
we call Juliet balcony doors so you
can't actually open them and walk out
onto the balcony you can just look
through them we've approached all the
neighbors predominately in Pride Road
and sex Lane and we took it on ourselves
to get a petition signed by 47 of the
neighbors to put their minds at rest we
obtained the signatures on a petition
stating they were happy with the work
being carried out and they raised no
objections to the project proceeding
mostly most importantly it's relevant I
think next door number see seconds
please okay thanks next doors carry out
extensive building and she signed the
petition as did the house opposite and
the one at the rear directly that would
be the only one affected by the balcony
build based damaged the wall they've
agreed to rebuild it and I'll skip to
the last bit finally I'd like to repeat
what Matt said earlier once we're aware
of the concerns we took immediate action
to address and comply with the planning
process we're probably a little bit
experienced we hope we've totally
improved the property greatly enhanced
the street scene we stopped complaining
now please yep just finishing we stopped
over work on the house in November
pending this meeting and Matt and I
would both love to be given a permission
to continue the work and finish the
project thank you balconies that you've
mentioned Juliet's just so I'm clear my
head these don't you you will not be
able to open these doors there that
permit locks or they are uh nope Neville
they can open inwards but preserve
there's a sort of a bar or a decorative
thing across there you can't open them
and walk out onto the so it's it's
almost like a railing in
I think I've seen and I've got a bit
confused but that's fine that's fine I
think a lot of apartments have them
where you need sort of a show isn't
there but you can actually walk nice to
have one on my phone yes good taste just
on the parking issue obviously remove
the carriage and turn in habitable space
and what are you going to do about the
parking spaces on the site and how many
parking spaces are you providing for for
it please to be honest with you that the
house was built in 1958 the company can
see the garage but a modern car
certainly a Range Rover or something
probably wouldn't fit in it but what
definitely wouldn't that van might just
about fit in it but you wouldn't be able
to get out so it wasn't much use as a
garage so we've can but our intention is
to convert it to accommodation living
the accommodation the drive without us
doing anything to it and it's not our
intention to do anything to drive to his
block page you just needs cleaning up
and we're going to landscape the front
the drive will easily handle six five
six five six cars without doing anything
so if there was an extra car it probably
wouldn't even be notice but I doubt very
much you'd get a reasonably sized modern
car in the garage no I appreciate that
sorry I was just asking how many power
parking spaces are being provided oh
you're saying five or six I think it's
five or six Drive anyway yeah thank you
the other questions members okay thank
you very much you just press the button
on the bottom of the microphone you're
thinking now remember so I'm sure you're
aware that accounts for Adams who's a
ward member in this area had an
unfortunate accident and is broken Iran
and so he's unable to attend this
evening and I've said an agreed excuse
me I will just really know what she said
I still object to this application
though even with the amendment although
the Balkans had been removed there still
remains a large patio windows no electus
these see these reduced in size to
conventional windows has been expect
sensitive work into a project extensive
work done on the rear garden and the
footprint of the extensions larger than
the exist
building this has all been done without
an archaeological dig taking place which
I feel in this part of the town should
have been carried out I'm very
disappointed some of the work is carried
out with our Planck mission and against
the advice of the enforcement officer I
think we can say that a number of those
items have been addressed and I just
wanna clarify those when we come to the
private time with the officer any
comments on that
otherwise you can go to technical
questions and I'll just raise those
particular items with the officer so
moving on to the the balcony have we
seen this
this is Greenville or wherever in front
of the making into Juliet balcony have
you seen that no as seen that in the
flesh I do note and bring two members
attention though that there is a
condition that requires those flat areas
above the rear extensions to an address
in the area and thank you
moving on to the repair of the frontage
because obviously the saying that the
Walton damage I assume that our heritage
operators will be looking at that this
is a type of development that we talked
about the ball at the front which is in
the conservation area
it's piercing that picture to have been
repaired and if it looks bright I
suspect that's because it's not
weathered unlike the rest of it at the
moment so it's not something that our
conservation obviously would normally
look at I picked up from the applicants
saying that it was going to be repaired
at least that's what I think I heard so
therefore I don't know what to think
when this photograph was taken and I'd
like that to be to be double-checked by
our heritage officer please
I can Buckham I can pick it up with
enforcement yeah okay any technical
questions cousin Thank You chair just to
clarify that the Juliet balconies can be
a condition but actually for the
building regulations would probably kick
in here because they wouldn't allow
opening doors without the Juliet balcony
all right I think what we've proposed at
this stage is a condition which prevents
the use of those areas on top of the
ground floor extensions as their balcony
or amenity space at all I think I think
what counts a lot I'm saying I kind of
understand this is if it's all very well
having that as a prevention of a minute
of space but if those doors to open and
they let's say for example as a child
and then they open the doors are open
which one's going to run out there
there's nothing to stop them falling off
that roof I think that's the issue I
think we do need to condition their
Juliet balconies if we can that's why I
thought building rates would kick in
because it's it's a health and safety
issue rather than a planning issue I
couldn't say for sure if it's cheap
locating building regs but that I don't
see the bigger concern with adding it to
condition for that there shall be the
the balustrade within the room sorry
outside the room because the doors open
inward and it sounds like that's been
done anyway but I don't think any harm
in putting that in the condition if that
would
okay anything else okay open debate
debate Thank You chair on that basis
with that provision for the Juliet
balcony I propose that we grant the
simplification thank you very much
indeed members we do have a vote before
us to grant a plan of mission for 17/2
to nine 4/4 all those in favor and those
against abstain thank you this committee
therefore resolves to grab pen pressure
something /o 2 to 9 for staff for thank
you
now then I'm just going to sign the
minutes which will take me about 30
seconds and thank you very much indeed
everybody good evening